[Music]
I think shield shouldered fine shall
they good it's probably gonna be hard I
[Music]
can't find my way through okay there's
my hand
oh man
this is so weird this could be him but
also no I don't think it's him it feels
like almost too much scruff and also
like an arrow or a nose
yeah I'm not totally sure but I have a
feeling that that was not Jacob this is
the weirdest thing I've ever done no way
this face is too small that's not him
yeah definitely not if this doesn't feel
like Jacob I don't know what I'm gonna
do
where is the face yeah that's makeup for
sure I think it's him because his beard
is fuller down here than it is up here
maybe not though I think one in three
hold on
come back guys this hard sorry I'm
feeling your mouth I don't know I'm
gonna say three I'm saying three yes
nailed it I knew it I knew it took a
while though yeah that was for sure
harder than I thought but I still won so
your face is smaller than I thought it
was though
[Music]